turned out of China where a major summit
is underway in Beijing as China
showcases its expansion of a key
infrastructure project known as the belt
and Road initiative leaders from 37
countries are discussing the gigantic
project with China's President Xi
Jinping now launched five years ago it's
set to boost trade between China and the
world there concerns that the project
could lead to a market monopoly by China
so what does the china belt and Road
initiative mean it's the new version of
the Silk Road what is it involved one
route runs through Central Asia and
Moscow all the way to Trieste in Italy
it consists of roads and railways as
well as power stations telecommunication
networks and pipelines now there is the
maritime Silk Road which will connect
China with Europe Africa and Southeast
Asia are China's already Invista
invested billions in infrastructure
projects along the way but critics are
warning that President Xi's gigantic
project is plunging its partners into
debt giving China increasing power
here's what the Chinese President had to
say the belton road is not an exclusive
club and it aims to promote green
development we are convinced that a more
open China will further integrate itself
into the world and deliver greater
progress and prosperity for China and
the world at large so for more let me
draw in our correspond matters
bourlingueur he is in Beijing now we had
a little bit of what a president she had
to say mattias a grand open to this
event what is China hoping to achieve
with this summit well I think first and
foremost this is a display of power Xi
Jinping's key ideology has been to
renascence of China as a world power and
having all these heads of state and
government
attending this conference in China for a
china-led project is of course a show of
China's new role a show that Xi Jinping
wants to show his own citizens and the
world besides that of course we will
also see some business deals
we are of course we see some side talks
along this summit but this this big
opening ceremony showed us that this is
about China's position in the world ok
so now we're seeing obviously it is an
expression of China's kind of position
in the world but they also controversy
about this belt and Road initiative some
people feel that is China's way of
expanding its influence and geopolitical
ambitions in the world
how does shanna respond to this
criticism this year has been extremely
critical to this project in many
countries governments who were China
friendly who had accorded two big deals
within this belt and wrote initiative
had been ousted had been voted out by
voters and opposition parties have won
who were criticizing these projects so
this comes at a critical point we have
just seen Xi Jinping's answer to this he
says it's not a one-way road so to say
he and that China is open to the world
this these are words up until now we are
likely to see some recalibration of the
project but we are seeing no signs that
China is making this into a multilateral
project with equal partners what is
building building in Beijing thank you
very much for that